no jaywalking on my watch there's a new
wash it'll crackdown underway with
police going after all those gadget fees
out there but it's not in a way that you
might expect to sound goes down in San
Francisco an undercover cop puts on a
bad guy hoodie and asks passers-by if
they want to buy a stolen iPhone or iPad
two other armed undercover officers
hanging out nearby and taste the deal
goes bad in a block away two more
officers wait in an unmarked car when
some shmo takes the bait he's busted
five cops to take down one iPhone thief
trying to cut the head of the snake off
so that there's no put there's no market
to sell the phone San Francisco PD is
big on ice Tings which also yield big
arrest numbers in the Big Apple as well
as DC but critics say it's a slimy an
ineffective tactic that hasn't even
taken a nibble out of Apple related
crimes then again these stings may
actually be a step up from the days when
San Francisco cops reportedly staggered
around Skid Row pretending to be drunk
dangling cash from their pockets and
busting homeless guys who tried to swipe
the moolah maybe it's a good way to pad
arrest stats but come on don't cups have
better things to do I cut about touching
more murderers and rapists the year
after the San Francisco PD admitted they
had thousands of unsolved murders and
rapes on their hands the local DA who
was police chief at the time of the
revelation admitted he had forgotten
about those unsolved crimes well let's
remember those crimes and remember
there's no need to trick random people
into breaking the law because lots of
people have already committed crimes go
catch them follow the show on Twitter
submit your nominees for next month and
check out deviant aalam this month's
featured follower and someone you should
definitely follow me are you twittering
me